Nobel Peace Prize for 2019 to Ethiopian
Prime Minister Ave Ahmed Ali the moment
Ethiopia's lead a herd of his
prestigious prize and with it
praise from his supporters at an
Ethiopian we have seen dr. ABI has
played a major role in championing
social justice and what we expect now is
after peace progress and development of
the nation of paramount is of paramount
importance sworn into office barely 18
months ago at the height of civil unrest
in Ethiopia and during a state of
emergency the 43 year old former army
intelligence officer hasn't shied away
from taking tough decisions his biggest
achievement is making peace with
neighbouring Eritrea following a 21 year
long conflict on their border which
began with war in 1998
ABI managed to re-establish normal
relations between the two countries he
also ordered the release from jail of
his critics opposition politicians and
journalists have even established a
Ministry of peace which includes some of
the government's most notorious
ministries such as the National
Intelligence Service and the police
force he's also trying to open up the
economy allowing foreign investors a
share in traditionally state-owned
monopolies it hasn't been easy though
ABI survived an assassin armed with a
grenade at a campaign rally last year
and inter-ethnic fighting nationwide
forced around three million people from
their homes
obby also survived an attempted coup a
few months ago by some soldiers unhappy
with his leadership for of Arby's close
allies including his chief of staff were
killed in the failed uprising in the
Amhara region and he's disappointed many
of the opions by failing to quickly
transform the economy the only problem
they have right now is they wanted the
change to happen immediately we have a
lot of economic problems in this country
although the economy is growing very
fast
the amount of expenditure that went into
infrastructure has been at the expense
of livelihoods a general election is due
next May some opposition supporters told
Al Jazeera that that will be the
ultimate test of his Peace Prize I
believe will help us an impetus for him
it will significantly improve his
legitimacy it will be understood and
Authority understood as an international
recognition for not only for him but you
know for the people and for the country
in going forward in tackling these
challenges and realizing the ambitions
of the mass dpmp before a democratic
inclusive in accountable States as the
Prime Minister received the news of his
prize he said he hoped it would promote
peace building efforts elsewhere in
Africa just get the news thank you very
much it is given to Africa here in
Ethiopia and I can I can imagine how the
rest of Africa leaders who take it
positively to work on peace building
process in our continent Abi's job of
keeping Ethiopia United and stable is a
big one but he's off to a good start as
this year's Nobel Peace Prize laureate
Robyn Kriel
al Jazeera Addis Ababa